yesterday a high school student shot up
a school in Iowa killing a little child
a sixth grade student and injuring five
other innocent people after which the
shooter killed himself according to news
reports the shooter left a final social
media post of a duffel bag hinting at
his crime his Tik Tok page which has
since been wiped featured an anime girl
as his Avatar and a bio highlighting the
LGBT pride flag another account
reportedly linked with the shooter
featured pronouns and a Reddit account
reportedly belonging to the shooter
interacted with Pages which is why you
can expect to hear nothing more about
this story when a politically convenient
villain commits such a crime a straight
white male say or a Christian the
shooting is blamed on the shooter's race
or sexual desires or religion when the
shooter's identity is ambiguous or
politically neutral the crime is blamed
on guns
but when the shooter's identity is
politically
inconvenient when the shooter calls
himself LGBT and especially when the
shooter identifies as the media cover it
up it's been 284 days since a criminal
shot up a Nashville Elementary School
still the political authorities refuse
to release any relevant information as
to the motive the only hope of stopping
these sorts of crimes is to tell the
truth about what motivat them lies and
delusion endanger citizens including the
most innocent among us but telling the
truth endangers the politically
convenient narrative guess which one our
political and journalistic leaders are
going to choose to protect I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Shila Buff is
now a Catholic he was just received into
the church there's a little bit of good
news uh turning back to government
corruption for a moment
though you know that Colorado has kicked
Trump off the ballot there uh that was a
a court in Colorado that did it state of
Maine also kicked Trump off of the
ballot that was just a Democrat
Secretary of State who did that now
Trump is appealing the Colorado decision
presumably this will have some effect
for all of the blue states that want to
kick him off the ballot he's appealing
that all the way up to the Supreme Court
he filed an appeal uh yesterday or
rather on Wednesday to overturn the
Colorado Supreme Court decision the
appeal says the question of Eligibility
to serve as president of the United
States is properly reserved for congress
not the state courts to consider and
decide by considering the question of
Trump's president Trump's eligibility
and borrowing him from the ballot the
Colorado Supreme Court arrogated
congress's Authority that's true uh if
this provision of the 14th Amendment um
is to be considered really at all it
would it would be considered and
interpreted by congress not by some
Court 150 years later because they don't
like the the mean orange man what do we
do about this obviously the the decision
to kick Trump off the ballot is
completely indefensible but the Supreme
Court follows public opinion polls
sometimes the Supreme Court reads the
newspapers too so I don't know that we
could count on a Justice Gorsuch or
Justice Kavanagh certainly not a Justice
Roberts to do the right thing here I
don't know I hope we can count on them
to do the right thing I just don't know
so what can we do to increase the odds
that Democrat operatives are not able to
Bor the most popular presidential
candidate in the country from the ballot
in the in the defense of democracy to
prohibit the people from voting for the
popular candidate what can we do I've
got an idea and this idea is not
actually my idea this is Jeremy's idea
but because someday I would I would be
really tickled if I became the president
of Harvard I'm just going to claim this
as my own idea and and we can leave it
at that even though Jeremy came up with
it a couple nights ago and I thought it
was pretty
smart a red State
Governor needs to have a red state
Secretary of State kick Biden off the
ballot I guess we could just skip the
first step go right to the red State
secretaries of state but the governors
tend to a little bit more political
influence and a little more interest in
the presidency so however it gets done I
don't really care but we need a red
state Secretary of State to kick Biden
off the ballot now and they can come up
with some explanation it will probably
be a more credible explanation than the
one that the Democrats have come up with
for kicking Donald Trump off the
ballot and then you give the Supreme
Court the freedom to say no no you guys
can't be kicking any presidential
candidates off the ballot we're going to
let the people decide but you've got to
give the Supreme Court some room some
some Grace
some plausible justification that will
appease half of our country which has
completely lost its mind as to why
they're going to let Donald Trump remain
on the ballot if if the Supreme Court
can look as though it is being neutral
on partisanship here and is just
defending democracy it's going to be a
lot easier for five or six justices or
more to say no actually Donald Trump
gets to remain on the ballot and the way
to do that is to use the left's tactics
against them what they've done in
Colorado is ridiculous what they've done
in Maine is even more ridiculous yeah I
agree but in in war and in politics your
opponent has a say as to how things go
and the libs are really going there the
libs are really trying to prohibit the
most popular presidential candidate in
the country from appearing on the on the
ballot so we've got to respond in kind
not in a way that's immoral not in a way
that's unjust we've got to respond in a
way that will
uh one be justifiable in and of itself
and I think as a political operation
this is and then two allow give the
Supreme Court the opportunity to make a
ruling that is just that is within the
American legal tradition and that
actually does defend democracy that's
how you're going to do it you want to
keep Trump on the ballot some red state
Secretary of State needs to grow some
gulun and kick Joe Biden off the bat
it's it would be very easy to do that
you there are so many crimes there's so
much evidence of corruption there's you
know you could even forget about Joe
Biden for a second
this I I responded to Jeremy when he
presented this idea that I'm now going
to claim as my own because I want to be
the president of Harvard I responded to
Jeremy I said you know no one claims
that Joe Biden LED an Insurrection he
said yeah okay then forget about Joe
Biden make it kamla Harris certainly we
can say kamla Harris LED an Insurrection
she personally fundraised for riers and
criminals who were
you don't even need to go after Joe
Biden but however you're going to do it
give the Supreme Court the opportunity
to say this isn't about partisanship
this isn't about Donald Trump it's about
all political candidates of all
political parties you you don't get to
just be some two bit political hack in
some random State and kick the candidate
you don't like the opposition party
nominee off the ballot because that's
not a good look when you want to look
good you got to check out Jus cell right
now go to Jus cell.com let's make a
resolution that's easy to keep and
delivers immediately on its promise with
genus cell skincare you can turn back
the clock and look 5 10 or even 15 years
younger right now genus cell skincare is
celebrating 2024 with its New Year's
Sales Event you will save over 70% off
all your genus cell must haves in their
most popular package say goodbye to
those Fine Lines forehead wrinkles
sagging jawline dark marks skin redness
even under eye bags leave them in 2023
genus cell works for women and men it's
safe for all skin types it is perfect
for skin of any age plus with its
immediate effects genus cell promises
results that will make you smile
guaranteed or 100% of your money back
right now for a limited time J cell's
top selling hyaluronic acid Serum is
included free in every most popular
package the girls at this office are
obsessed with the hyaluronic acid all
you hear walking around hyaluronic acid
this and hyaluronic acid that they can't
get enough of it it's great it's a
wonderful company they use the absolute
best ingredients out there the founder
is a Coptic Christian from Egypt who
came here for the American dream enjoy
maximum skin hydration for a more
youthful look Jus cell.com enter code
nles at checkout for extra savings every
order automatically upgraded to free
shipping don't wait jus.com
speaking of the radical left there is a
leftist politician in Boston a new
Boston City councelor this woman is an
immigrant and she has become a Boston
city counselor well she was about to be
sworn into office she and her fellow
politicians were were being sworn into
office but she refused to raise her hand
or take the oath I do solemnly swear I
do swear that I will faithfully and
impartially discharge I will
Faithfully hand form all the
duties all the duties incumbent on me
incumbent on me as a member of the
Boston city council as a of looking down
according to the best of my ability and
understanding ACC to
my
ability agreeably to the rules and
regulations agre to the rules and
regulations of the Constitution and the
laws of this common love of the
Constitution and the laws of this common
so help me God so help me God yeah can't
do that she can't do that can she
because she doesn't support the
political order of Boston or
Massachusetts she doesn't support the
Constitution I I'm not convinced she
supports God she's not going to do any
of that she wants to be on the city
council but she doesn't want to take the
oath to uphold the very basic
requirements of the job so she should
obviously be thrown out of office as far
as I'm concerned she should be deported
she she doesn't like this country she
won't uphold the the absolute most basic
principles of this country why do we
want her why do we want her here what
good is she for
America if if you come to America and we
take you in and then you s you say yeah
I I won't even say that I will support
the
Constitution then go go away we don't
want you here you know that should be I
think the minimum threshold and there
there should be many more requirements
we have a country that is teeming with a
non-native born population and that
creates all sorts of social
problems because you need to assimilate
if you want to have a country so there
are so many more layers of requirements
that we should have for immigration but
I think the basic one is hey you like
the country you you'll support the
Constitution oh no you won't okay
bye-bye see you see you later her name
is Tanya Fernandez
Anderson and uh she she's got a track
record of radicalism she's offered
resolutions in the past for uh September
23rd to be Boston's hijab day which by
the way this is going to be an unpopular
take I'm not totally opposed to I guess
I'm opposed to that day for Boston
because Boston is not a Muslim City and
America is not a Muslim country but I I
actually don't hate the
hijab I I actually think hijabs can be
kind of pretty sort of a very
traditional piece of headwear we've had
all sorts of similar pieces of headwear
in the West for a long time it's very
modest it's not a full burka
okay not even a ncab it's just a nice
little head scarf I I have no problem
with it I don't think we need his job
day in Boston but okay actually that's
the that's that's probably the best
thing This Woman's ever done in
politics it's like a it's like a further
Easter Mantia that's okay uh she has
called on Boston to apologize for the
Atlantic slave trade Boston had very
little to do with the Atlantic slave
trade compared to other uh parts of the
Western Hemisphere had basically nothing
to do with the Atlantic slave trade and
by the way slavery has existed
everywhere on Earth for all of human
history what what distinguishes the west
from the rest of the world is that we
actually ended slavery slavery still
exists in a a large part of the world
today the place it is least likely to be
found is in the west so that's obviously
ridiculous this woman has a history of
anti-white tweets she doesn't like white
people she doesn't like white people
holding government positions so that's
no good uh oh she married a murderer she
married a convicted murderer while he
was in prison for life this is CRA this
is just according to news reports hard
to believe all this stuff she referred
to the October 7th pgr by Hamas onto the
state of Israel as a simply a military
operation which if it was anything it
was not simply a milit operation because
it targeted civilians so it was a
terrorist
attack there are military operations
that are just there are military
operations that are unjust but something
that would distinguish a a mere military
operation from a terrorist attack would
be the targeting of civilians which
Hamas obviously engaged in so anyway the
woman seems like a complete nut and a
just society would not only remove her
from the the city council but would
Deport her okay we have a major major
immigration crisis I like all sorts of
immigrants a lot of us descend at least
in some part of our family from
immigrants so I'm not saying I'm I'm
totally anti-immigrant but immigration
always we see this in political
philosophy and history going back to
Antiquity all the way consistently
through up to the present day
immigration creates many many political
problems and so while we while we will
tolerate and sometimes even encourage
some degree of immigration we got to be
very very careful about it and people
who come to your country and say and
demonstrate quite clearly that they hate
everything about your country they got
to go they got to go man now we're not
we're not bringing the best we're not
hiring the best and speaking of not
hiring the best Dei is facing a major
credibility crisis brought on largely by
this Harvard president debacle
because the Harvard president the former
Harvard president was a big promoter of
Dei she herself is a Dei or Proto Dei
kind of hire she had a ridiculously
pathetic academic record she had 11
scholarly Publications she seemed to
have copied a lot of it but even if she
hadn't plagiarized much of her
publication history to have 11
Publications by the time you reach the
Pinnacle of Academia is very sad you
should have 11 academic Publications
when you're in graduate school okay
forget about throughout your faculty
career and then becoming the president
of Harvard it's pathetic and we all know
that this woman got her job because she
ticked all the politically correct boxes
and that's why it was difficult to fire
her until it wasn't until finally she
was out so a a big Dei debate has
erupted and Mark Cuban who is the
liberal owner of the Dallas Mavericks he
comes out and uh he he defends Dei so JD
Vance the conservative senator from Ohio
he says hey Mark did the Dallas
Mavericks reflect the demographics of
America as a
whole this one of the lines from the Dei
people including Mark cubin we need to
have racial quotas in our companies and
our school schs and our organizations
because we need these organizations to
reflect the diversity of America and by
diversity we mean certain racial and
sexual
criteria now turns out the Dallas
Mavericks do not reflect the racial
demographics of America they reflect all
sorts of demographics of America so
Cuban responds to him and he he doesn't
actually respond to the point he doesn't
acknowledge the point he just goes on a
tie raade but the tie raade I think
undermines the whole Dei movement Mark
humanman says if you were trying to make
a stupid comment you nailed it first as
an organization as a whole yes we
do what does that mean the the
executives are white but the players are
black is that what he's saying I don't
know that that reflects very well I
either says yes we do more importantly
though if you understand the value of
Dei it's not in checklists and quotas
it's in understanding how to best
compete as a company we hire the people
who put us in the best position to
succeed
now we all know that that isn't true
Mark Cuban I think knows that that isn't
true I think he's got to be lying here
it's the most charitable read I can have
here is that he's lying he couldn't
possibly be this
stupid if it were the case that Dei
policies make companies more
competitive then why do the big activist
investor funds and the government
Regulators have to mandate the Dei
policies why do they have to Ram them
down the company's throats why do they
have to threaten the companies if the
companies don't comply with Dei why do
the investor the the activist investor
funds have to say we're going to pull
our money out of your company we're
going to tank your stock price if you
don't comply with Dei if Dei is so good
for the
company that doesn't seem to make a lot
of sense if if Dei policies just
naturally made a company better the
companies would eagerly adopt
them it it it's the same error that you
see when feminist activists say that
women make 75 cents on the dollar that
that men do and we just know that isn't
true that might literally be true in
that
women leave the workforce to become
mothers in that women are less
aggressive about negotiating raises in
that women work shorter hours as as a
whole and that's true men and women are
different they behave differently so
maybe ultimately they get paid
differently but the the feminist claim
that women make 75 cents on the dollar
for doing the exact same work as men
that's obvious ridiculous if that were
the case companies would only hire women
you think companies hate women or
something you think you think you'd tell
a Fortune 500 company hey you can save
25% of your labor costs if you hire
women but Rich Uncle Penny bags in the
sea Suite says no I hate those women you
kidding me I'm not letting some skirt in
here no way I don't pay I don't care if
we have to pay 200% more for our labor
costs I just hate those bras those
ladies I don't think so I think they
would hire the women in two
seconds but it's just not true and the
Dei thing is not true and it's very
clear Dei is being exposed here Dei
policies prioritize leftist social
engineering
over competitiveness over productivity o
but and over this is the important part
over fairness we all know that this is
so deeply
unfair most people have been raised to
believe that racial discrimination that
that being told you can't do something
you can't get a job you can't go to a
certain school because of the color of
your skin that that is unfair and ugly
and not nice and what Dei does is
exactly that says oh yeah you're a
little too pale sorry no job sorry no
admission to schools yeah Oh no you're a
little too straight if you if you gay if
you gay yourself up a little bit then
maybe we'll consider you but n you
straight guy h no you're a Christian nah
not GNA work sorry we all know that's
unfair and so the best defenses they
have are the bloviations of a guy like
Mark Cuban which is not not very
persuasive my favorite comment yesterday
is from Eric
K H he says I hate how right you are
about the Epstein prediction I know I
there was a moment when I made my
predictions for the new year n stradamus
took out his crystal bow I made my
predictions and then truly within 24
hours I said we're not going to get any
significant new information on Epstein
we're not going to really see The Client
List 24 hours later the headlines we're
going to see The Client List we're going
to get the documents and I said oh darn
maybe I was
wrong nah I'm not wrong this is a total
fake out this is a total sop and
then sorry to tell you I was totally
right speaking of hiring people on
criteria other than Merit is a woman who
works for MSNBC she's an anchor
there perhaps a perfectly nice woman I
have nothing against her but she was
just putting in a very bad position her
name is Alicia
Menendez and she was conducting an
interview on
MSNBC but she had to stop because there
was breaking news and it was breaking
news that she could not really break
herself it was already awkward enough as
it is she had to hand off the news cast
to one of her colleagues because the
breaking news was that her father is
being brought up on even more corruption
charges thank you so much for your
expertise and for spending some time
with us we going to take a quick break
and we'll back with some breaking news
right after
this hello I'm Mari M with some breaking
legal news New Jersey United State
Senator Robert Menendez now facing new
allegations in a second superseding
indictment which is filed by a Federal
grand jury from his doj
prosecution pretty awkward pretty
awkward and it's not the first time that
we've seen this do you remember during
covid you had Chris Cuomo the Fredo of
the Cuomo family he was on CNN he was he
was a a journalist a neutral serious
news anchor and you had his brother Andy
guomo was the governor of New York who
had a pretty good PR team at least at
first and everyone said that he was
doing the greatest job even though
people kept dying in New York at really
high rates somehow everyone said oh
Cuomo he's doing the best oh I'm I'm so
attracted to what Cuomo's doing here
there was a video that went viral a girl
said I'm a cuomosexual that's how how
beautiful and attractive what he's doing
is and then it turned out he was cooking
the books he was killing senior citizens
in nursing homes he just completely blew
it and ultimately they threw him out of
office but at the time it was awkward
for Fredo guomo on CNN because he would
interview his brother and give him these
puff piece interviews oh you're doing a
great job brother don't forget to call
Mom anyway you're doing amazing bro ah
yeah backslap backs slap and then the
news comes out that it was all a big lie
and Chris is stuck on air he uh all
right we got to go we're going to cut to
someone else now because he he can't
cover his brother
critically just like Alicia Menendez you
can't expect her to cover her father's
newest corruption allegations but the
reason this is a problem for people like
CNN and and MSNBC is because of the
incestuous political environment where
the journalists this the so-called
fourth estate and the uh politician
class and the lobbyists and they're all
related sometimes they're literally in
bed together because they're sleep
sleeping with each other sometimes
they're under the same roof because
they're brothers or sisters or fathers
or Sons or married or whatever but
they're all just
related the Democrats have a very
incestuous political apparatus the
Republicans really don't but it really
it really knocks their
credibility because while CNN and MSNBC
claim to to be the Intrepid journalists
doing a dangerous job speaking truth to
power they can't do that they can't even
speak truth to their brother they can't
even speak truth to their father
they can't then how did they get their
jobs Chris Cuomo he's
a somewhat articulate decent enough
looking guy and I guess he could be on
TV but did he get his job because he's
the greatest TV presenter ever or did he
get his job because he's a Cuomo and his
dad was the governor of New York and
then his brother became the governor of
New York and he's a very prominent
Democrat how'd it
happen the Menendez family there are
many other political families where the
the big star is a politician and then a
lot of the rest of the family goes into
journalism how much can we trust that
journalism not very much I think
speaking of the Democrats political
apparatus Democrats are facing a major
crisis of popularity a lot of it driven
by
immigration immigration we're not really
allowed to say it but immigration is the
issue it is the issue that is motivating
major populist uprisings not just in
America but throughout the West it it
motivated the brexit it has fueled
Victor orban's uh prime minister ship in
Hungary it fueled Georg Malone's
election in Italy it's fueled Donald
Trump's election don't forget his big
issue and we're going to build the wall
Mexicans are rapists and murderers and
some I assume are good people and it's a
big issue and you just look at the
numbers now if if you look on any chart
of of US border encounters that IL
immigration was pretty high under Obama
and then it dropped for a little bit
under Trump and it SP liked up again
because the libs wouldn't let Trump
enforce border policies it kind of went
down though it was roughly on par with
Obama's and then under Biden it just
shoots through the roof it
doubles the only explanation for that is
that the Biden Administration is
encouraging Mass migration and we know
that I mean Joe Biden said come please
surge come come to the Border we're not
going to enforce the Trump policies
anymore we're not going to build it
we're going to dismantle this wall
actually and now he's had to kind of try
to reverse course and say well maybe we
we'll build part of the wall but they
have no idea what what they want to do
the message is to totally contradictory
and then we hear the real story from the
the DHS secretary Alejandra mayorcas who
says that they're not going to implement
policies that discourage immigration we
need additional Asylum officers to
really accelerate the Asylum
adjudication process so people are not
waiting six years before they receive
their results which is in effect a pull
factor the fact that people can stay
here for six years before before their
Asylum cases adjudicated is a powerful
example of how broken our immigration
system is and has been for so long we
are focused on the fundamental solution
to a long-existing problem and that
fundamental solution is legislation we
have taken actions already to build
lawful Pathways to deliver consequences
and do what we can we've promulgated
regulations to do what we can within the
confines of the law but fundamentally
the law is the laws themselves must
change and this is something about which
everyone agrees and that is quite rare
when one is speaking about immigration
hey did you hear anything practical in
that
rambling
nothingness I didn't you know what I
heard from Alejandra mayorcas Alejandra
mayorcas was asked will you reimplement
the remain and Mexico policy there's a
policy that Trump reinstituted which
said hey if if you say that you're
fleeing Guatemala or Honduras or
Nicaragua or wherever because of
political persecution then all right um
You got to stop in a in countries where
you're free from political persecution
you don't need to go through 10
different
countries you don't unless you're an
economic migrant you want to come to the
US to make a buck which is obviously
what a lot of this is about but if it's
about fleeing persecution if it's about
fleeing disease or whatever it is then
okay then stay in Mexico the very latest
remain there and mayorca says no we're
not going to do that because they want
to they want to flood the country with
migrants because they think it gives
them a political advantage and in fact
it does now before we get to my favorite
time of the week the mailbag little bit
of happy news speaking of bringing
people in which is that shy lauff shy
lauff is now a Catholic he was received
into the Catholic Church by Bishop Baron
who was on this show couple of weeks ago
and this is really great news we'd heard
while Shia was making this movie about
Padre Pio that uh he was interested in
converting to Catholicism he said that
the traditional Latin mass is what
really attracted him that's true of so
many young people and young converts
they're not attracted by the church
trying to Wed herself to the spirit of
the age which leaves when you wed
yourself to the spirit of the age you
become a widow in the next age uh Shia
was attracted to the mass of the ages
the enduring mass that formed the vast
majority of saints throughout history
and and now he's been received into the
church and that's really great news and
the reason I mention it it's not just
because I think it's good for Shia or
because I want mael snapping papist
myself but because it's a reminder that
the worst times are often the best times
we're living through very very difficult
times for the country for our culture in
the church there's a crisis in the
church going on right
now and yet you think about this in your
own life the the the worst times the
most stressful times the most difficult
times you look back on them often you
say well those were the best times why
because
they can either destroy you I guess
that's not good or if you survive them
those are often the most edifying times
those are often the most sanctifying
times those are the decisive moments and
you know we believe in Providence you're
here for a reason it's a great honor to
be placed in the world at a at a
difficult and challenging time and so
that's good it might be the worst time
but the worst times are often the best
times okay it's no question that we are
living in a clown World basic Notions of
right wrong Justice truth even reality
itself have been thrown out the window
how are we to make sense of all of this
well join my friend Jonathan Pou in the
new four-part series end of the world as
he explains why the world is we know it
is ending how to survive it how we can
plant the seeds for the next world today
Jonathan peso is an iconographer a
public speaker a YouTuber a very close
friend of Jordan Peterson you might
remember pjo from his Illuminating
comments in Jordan series on Exodus now
he's back and will'll draw upon his deep
knowledge of Christian tradition stories
mythology and history to explain the
contradiction in our society wacky
phenomena and how this pattern will
reach its conclusion in end of the world
you will receive a thoughtful framework
to make sense of these confusing times
and a roadmap to lead us out of the
clown world and restore order all
episodes are available now exclusively
on dailywire plus if you haven't become
a member this is the perfect time go to
dailywire.com subscribe unmask the
Carneys CB on the end watch end of the
world
today finally finally we've arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by P talk at PE
talk.com kwes today take it away
my best friend has a doctorate in
English and spent much of his education
studying feminism and gender Theory so
he maintains that gender is a purely
social construct that is in no way
informed by biological sex I attempted
to argue the idea that a majority of men
or women would inform the idea of the
genders at a base level and he denied
that stating that there is no individual
aspect of either masculinity or
femininity that holds up under
concentrated scrutiny for example women
are more likely to desire to be the
primary child care provider is not
something he'd agree with because he'd
say that there's no objective way to
prove that this is true from a
biological standpoint as opposed to
cultural influence just because a
majority conforms to those
characteristics or believes they exist
doesn't mean that they are rooted in
reality he points to supposedly
gender-based Concepts throughout history
that have been proven false like the
belief that women are less intelligent
than men as evidence that my
argumentation methodology is flawed and
that because it's based in the concept
of the majority it doesn't hold up to
his
counterarguments I know that he would
welcome a compelling and intellectually
sound
rebuttal your your friend seems rather
confused he he says that you can't prove
that women are more likely to desire a
certain thing but of course you can
prove that you would just take a public
opinion poll hey women are you more
likely than men to desire to be mothers
obviously the vast majority of women
would say yes
so that proves it he says well there's
no scientific way to prove what are you
talking about scient what's the what's
the scientific way to prove desire you
ask somebody and they describe their
will and their desire to you and then
you have your
answer well uh okay but they shouldn't
desire that that's the next question
right well there's nothing natural about
that desire well I don't know most women
for all of history have desire that so
is there not something natural about
that more to the point is there not some
something natural about culture are
these things totally divorced one from
the other your friend brings up this
argument he says for a lot of history
people thought women were stupider than
men women are different from men women's
Brains work differently for men women
reason in a different way than men do
Larry Summers got fired from Harvard
another president of Harvard who got
fired he was pushed out of the Harvard
presidency for making this point in 2006
he just pointed at a chart and said that
the IQ bell curve for men and women are
different and for for men it's just it's
wider so he said at the high at the
absolute highest levels of intelligence
levels much higher than the IQs of me or
anyone else that we're talking about
today the very very highest IQ people on
earth almost certainly to be men and the
dumbest people on earth almost certainly
to be certain to be men because the the
bell curve is just wider and some
evidence for this would be that no woman
had ever won the fields prize the Fields
medal which is the highest uh award in
mathematics until this became a big
controversy and then something like 10
years after that a woman finally won the
the fields medal but that that would be
it because women have won all sorts of
prizes and done all sorts of great
scholarly work I'm not denying any of
that but at the very very very highest
outlier Peak there are some differences
yeah so it's Politically Incorrect to
say but you know if your buddy so
obsessed with science you know I suppose
one would want to fire follow the
science though when you do follow the
science and you get fired from Harvard
if you're Larry Summers other people get
fired from Harvard for other reasons I I
guess what I would ask your friend
is where does culture come from where
does Society come from why do we do the
things that we do that are socially
constructed do those social
constructions have any basis in reality
in in physical reality
even do physical things imply
metaphysical
things is this leftist tis tumbler can
we deduce from the physical
characteristics of the leftist Tumblr
that it is good for certain things and
bad for other things that it's better
for some things than for other things
can we deduce just looking at the Tumblr
that the Tumblr is better for bringing
leftist tears into my mouth than it is
for playing
guitar we can do that okay
can we not say the same thing about
people and our roles in society I think
we probably can next one good morning
Michael this is Arun a year ago you gave
an epically triggering and based speech
entitled science is fake in which you
made a distinction between reality and
what we think of as objective physical
truth I don't disagree with anything you
said but I was bothered by the potential
loss of objective truth your colleague
Dr Spencer claven recently cited a
passage from Einstein's book on the
theory of relativity which may help
explain your view Einstein states that
in Newtonian physics and even the
special theory of relativity so you know
relativity with no gravity any point in
the universe can be uniquely defined by
its coordinates so three spatial and one
temporal but in the general theory of
relativity this no longer holds because
any matter distribution that is present
will create a gravitational field that
warps the coordinate system itself
Einstein states that the unique
definition of a point can thus no longer
be defined solely by its coord
but by its encounters with other points
with other matter what I think he means
here is that while the objective truth
of a Point's coordinates can be faked
simply by doing a coordinate
transformation I suppose its
interactions with other matter cannot be
so we cannot say whether the Earth or
the Sun is the center of any defined
coordinate system but we can say that
the Earth and Sun are definitely
orbiting each other around some common
Berry Center would you say that this is
the equivalent of defining reality in
terms of objective reality coupled with
the subjective reality of our experience
with it and does that better comport
with your understanding of truth thank
you as always for your Insight it's a
very astute and aidite way to put it a
rune as always and yes that's that's
quite good the way I put it because I
don't have all that good science jargon
would would be a phrase like Owen
barfields uh saving the appearances or
Pierre duhem's uh keeping the phenomena
I for which way they're saying much the
same thing and that's what that's what
you're describing as well very good as
always very good har next one Michael
and episode 1187 you talked about who
Democrats could feel that could beat
Trump whether it was only Biden who
could do so or somebody else actually
nobody really cares who Democrats put up
for their nominee we know Biden didn't
beat Trump the first time Trump won by
over 15 million votes but their mail
ballot fraud machine made up 20 million
votes Biden is just a puppet for
Democrats Marxist Shadow government
their male ballot fraud has enabled them
to win the last three years as well as
squashing Republican hopes by falsely
blaming Trump policies that 80% of the
country wants brought back if
Republicans don't do something to stop
them from cheating then even Trump can't
win in 2024 they could nominate a
cockroach and win unless their ballot
fraud machine is
dismantled I agree in principal I don't
know about the numbers and the extent
and you know I don't I actually don't
think they need to generate all those
millions of fake ballots or you know do
anything in some shadowy bunker all
throughout the country I think really
elections come down to like three places
in the country and tens of thousands of
votes hundreds of thousands at the at
the most could could swing elections so
I agreed that there was obviously
rigging and I think there's solid
evidence of fraud in crucial places
there's no no question about any of that
so where does that leave us for 2024
I don't think that they could run uh you
know a snail I don't think they could
put a literal corpse up there and win I
mean I do
think either the rules have to be so
thrown up in the air or elections have
to be somewhat close in order for fraud
really to to make a difference uh now
they haven't done covid again they
they've tried to do Co again and and
people haven't really gone for it but
they did try to push okay we're going to
mask a little more and social distance a
little more and they obviously want to
push the widespread mailin it didn't
really take
uh it would be very difficult for them
to say oh Joe Biden wins by 50 gazillion
votes at a time when all the public
opinion polls reflect that he's the
least popular president ever by a long
shot uh so I agree the ballot fraud is a
major issue some of that's been
tightened up and barring another
pandemic perhaps that'll that'll be
enough to make it make it through next
one hey Dirty Mike F reality here I
wanted to talk to you about something
you said on Monday about January 6 2020
uh running on that sort of issue how you
can't really move on and the only way uh
to get past it is through my question is
uh for Trump or DeSantis or Haley
whoever ends up winning the uh
nomination couldn't they just not talk
about January 6th with the running since
it's proven uh pretty much that people
in the middle moderates Independence
nobody wants to talk about that anymore
they want to be done they want to move
on it seems like con ly harping on 2020
is going to cost whoever is on our side
the election so why don't they just not
talk about it and then do something
about it when they're actually in office
um so I don't think anybody's going to
actually stop the election from being
rigged Trump doesn't seem to be doing
anything about it um the santis has said
he would use leftist tactics against
them like ballot harvesting and stuff
where it's legal um but regardless
wouldn't it be better to not talk about
something that will cost you an election
and just do something about it once
you're elected thanks it would be we
just don't have that opportunity because
they're Prosecuting the president for
January 6th so you know it will be in
the news it will be an issue it will be
a major issue and and so the the way to
respond I guess it's one of two ways
Trump can say look look I want to move
on I just want to talk about taxes okay
I don't want to talk about 2020 that's
behind us Kumbaya or he can say they
rigged it and they're trying to throw me
in the can because they're the most
corrupt people ever and and think not
only is he certainly going to say the
the latter response but he kind of has
to it the prosecutions are an issue and
they're all around January 6th and I
don't think it necessarily will cost us
the election there's a poll that just
came out forget which Outlet put it out
which showed that among all three
political groups Republicans Democrats
and
independents Americans today are less
likely to believe that the Biden
election was legitimate than they were
in 2021 in 2021 the numbers were
anywhere from 3 to six points higher in
terms of believing that the election was
credible so the the January 6th
propaganda really hasn't worked for the
Democrats why because they told us that
a a capital officer was murdered by a
Crazy right-winger by who threw a a fire
extinguisher at his head we know that
was a lie we were told that this was an
Insurrection over through the government
we know that these people didn't have
any weapons we were told that they
overran the cops we know that the cops
LED them through the capital in certain
cases we were told that that poor public
servants were were killed as a result of
this we know the one person who was
killed in the political violence of
January 6th was a trump supporter killed
by a trigger happy cop we were told that
these were racist Neo-Nazi people it
wasn't it was Midwestern Granny's and
eccentric people wearing horn hats it
just it was all lies you know and and we
we now know that they're lies because
we've gotten some of that footage we've
seen some of the prosecutions we've seen
that these guys have been held in
solitary confinement for a very very
long time and most Americans including
Democrats think that the prosecutions of
trump are politically motivated and
Banana Republic kind of stuff so you
know ironically the focus on January 6th
has really I think helped the
Republicans now would it be better if we
could just avoid it all all together and
just focus on what a terrible President
Biden is yeah I guess so but we can't we
don't have that opportunity because the
Democrats are not going to let us have
that opportunity all right the rest of
the show
continues now it's fake headline Friday
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code NS kwes at check out for
2 months free n annual
[Music]
plans